مقترح هدنه وموافقه ثنائيه وعهود
بالالتزام ومن ثم ترحيب دولي سيناريو
متطابق تكرر 6 مرات على مدار اسبوعين في
السودان دائما ما ينتهي بالطريقه ذاتها
دون اي نتائج مرجوه مع تبادل طرفي الصراع
الاتهامات بخرقها
اولى المحاولات كانت يوم الثامن عشر من
ابريل لمده 24 ساعه ليتم خرقها باشتباكات
في الخرطوم وهي وليده ساعات اما الثانيه
هدنه قصيره المدى لمده 24 ساعه انتهت قبل
ان تبدا بالطريقه ذاتها التي انتهت فيها
الاولى
هي اول هدنه تمتد لثلاثه ايام طوال ايام
عيد الفطر او كما يفترض ذلك انتهت
باشتباكات متفرقه
تمديد للسابقه لمده 72 ساعه في يومي
الخامس والعشرين والسابع والعشرين من
ابريل تم تعبي ببساطه امريكيه لكن
الانفجارات والاشتباكات استمرت خلالهما
واجهت مصاعب قبل تطبيقها حتى فالاشتباكات
كانت تدور جنوبي الخرطوم مع تحليق لسلاح
الجو السوداني ورد مضادات الطائرات من
قوات الدعم السريع
خروق كانت بشكل اساسي في نقاط حساسه مثل
محيط القياده العامه في الخرطوم والقصر
الرئاسي بالاضافه الى اندرمان وبحري
واقليم دارفور
هدن لا تبصر النور لم تكن اي منها مفتاحا
لفتح باب المفاوضات ووقف القتال في البلاد
ولم تنجح اي منها حتى في السماح بفتح
ممرات انسانيه لمساعده الاهالي باوضاعهم
المترديه الى عمر العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات